[Music]
my first guess is of course an emmy
award-winning comedian who was starred
in the hbo series curb your enthusiasm
she's been in many films including the
greatest movie of all time pewdie tang
please welcome one sykes you always have
to say pootie i love saying pooty tang
it's the greatest title of a film ever
it's a great movie but the greatest
title ever
tang it is my only regret is they never
said and the oscar for best film goes to
booty
tag that would have been so great at
least best script right exactly i mean
you know you put soda tate and you get
this
exactly you would think something it's
funny no matter where i where i'm at you
know if i'm doing a show it could be
anywhere i mean no matter what the age
of the audience right somebody yells out
pooty time yeah and and whenever
somebody goes i love pooty tang you're
basically telling me you smoke weed yes
basically
it's just not uh you conan no no no not
me
um
high fiber diet for me uh
we got so much to talk about first of
all i want to get your opinion on this
newsweek cover came out this week and uh
it is getting so much uh attention and
uh people are saying they pretty much
have uh
got at this
the first gay president
president uh barack obama and i'm just
curious uh of course it's been a very
controversial cover not sure how the
president feels about it how do you what
do you think about this
it's so junior high you know it's like i
mean really i mean just because you say
you're you're for
gay bearish that doesn't make you gay
you know it's like you know it's like oh
you like equality you're so gay you know
it's almost it's like that and and
he yeah if they want to really say like
the first gay president
you know he should have been like in
drag or something you know
they've just they have made a people
have comment on this he's a gay angel
with crazy superpowers i mean
but you think you you think it'd be
better if they put them in drag or
something well i mean come on it's just
silly i mean you know the president said
hey i'm for equality he didn't say you
know i'm going to go beyond rupaul's
drag race you know it's like
he did come out with that announcement
later
yeah i missed that he's going to make
the rounds yeah
i got to ask you about uh of course
crazy stuff happening on wall street uh
jp morgan a major j.p morgan executive
uh stepped down people are resigning at
jp morgan they think there's going to be
more and more people stepping down
because of this right because of this
crisis they lost how much money two
billion dollars two billion dollars the
thing they lost two billion dollars
right and that they announced that on
friday and then sunday they announced
that the guy you know responsible was
stepping down i'm like we didn't even
need that announcement because if you
lose two billion dollars don't show up
at work
don't even you know what you think you
can just you know show up yeah
morning
anybody see the game
good coffee huh
uh mary do i have any calls
yeah they're looking for the two billion
exactly you lose two billion dollars you
just don't show up i mean come on man
yeah what about the uh i have to get
your take on the the secret service
scandal that uh of course involving uh
prostitutes secret service agents hiring
prostitutes did you you followed this
story yeah now this this is just
to me the story
what i wanted to see was when the secret
service that the when those guys showed
up at home and they're facing their
wives that's the story right there right
you know because it's all over the news
all over the news and you walk in and
your wife is just sitting there just
waiting for you
home early huh
what's he gonna say at that point uh
baby it was crazy uh
you know it was these crazy hookers were
um
coming at the president and uh i shot
two of my face
[Laughter]
and uh yeah it was crazy it was crazy so
it's not gonna have some time off now
yeah and it was over what one guy was
arguing over a 47 bill like you know
right that was 47 i mean have you seen
the beautiful women in
i mean 47 is nothing i would even tipt
you know
just come up with the money let's come
up with the money man 47
that's just i don't know yeah
shrugs me it bugs you i can tell it bugs
you it's just and the thing that's
getting you most is the price
like that's a good bargain you know if
you don't know a bargain you shouldn't
be protecting the president